ragazzi fantastici e belli come state
c'era un video che ho registrato diretta
in live vede una prima volta e facendo
questa del genere ma quella live è stata
talmente epica che ho fatto che ho detto
devo prendere quel pezzo renderlo un
video durante la live di un paio di
settimane fa o forse tre settimane fa ho
giocato agli under simulator la giocata
che ho fatto è uscita talmente bella e
talmente epica che ho voluto tenere da
parte quel video per poi rimontarlo e
far uscire un episodio figo dedicato
quindi questo e roland nel cimitero che
ho fatto qualche settimana fa in live
però montato è fatto bene perché questa
registrazione merita di uscire con i
video vedrete presto perché gender is
your ideal note gmail ma come la prima
cosa che ho fatto
cosa vuoi scegliere maschio femmina
femmina
no non puoi avere da allora salve o mio
dio cosa è successo a gesù è forse
l'hanno aggiornato così successo qua
cos'è la band delle forze che parlano
posso fare gossip chiaro yamada chi è
chi lo conosce
sorry nevermind lo staccata dal gruppo
poverina nolan aggiornato perché ci sono
cose perché quest'anno l'innaffiatoio
dietro siamo sicuri che l'hanno
aggiornato perché qua vedo cose molto
strane
va bene e io dovrei fare la stessa cosa
ma non la faccio
dov'è il mio sempai ecco la coda davanti
si è lui si tesoro self i guai don
knotts posso farmi dei self assetti mod
io sto camminando a caso che figata che
faccia fa guarda la faccia
va bene che in classe come si fa dov'è
che come si faceva da attivare il coso
per terra che dice dove devo andare a
eccola col articolati ho trovato però
c'è un tostapane in bocca ok per ora di
pranzo tutti che scappano che dei
compagni che ciò questo è veramente un
figo non so come ho fatto non
innamorarmi di lui
che roba non ci può neanche parlare
comunque ragazzi c'è una roba molto più
[ __ ] di prima che adesso nonostante
abbiano cambiato anche un po le skin dei
personaggi che lo rende molto più figo
adesso sembra che la sua sia proprio più
piena di gente o strano
fatemi andare a fatevi trovare delle
robe 9 allora fai vai a fare a botte con
i tipi di fuori va bene questa mi segue
quello che ti spacco le corna non
toccare le ragazze con le divise bianche
sono con i prof marco ha da to sorella
c'è mai spinto per un ora ma io lo
ammazzo altro che hanno toccato e il
coltello ed eccolo
vabbè vado a picchiare la gente vicina
all'inceneritore ragazzi per capire cosa
serve sta roba
va bene allora 2 per quelli del coltello
è nuova da mena i bulli ma ora che figo
è cambiato tutto
che storia ragazzi mi ha detto di
picchiarmi schiatta maledetto ad
ammazzare a te vojo mannaia la morte ma
muovi ti sei mai under
a prender load 5 peccato non mi portano
dalla consuelo che dicono no mi dispiace
non volevo ho sbagliato ma i bulli sono
lì sempre cioè che quando arrivi ma non
lavora anche vista sta roba
a queste sono le docce giusto guarda che
repulsione scioperi lo spogliatoio dei
maschi c'è proprio uno schifo va bene
noti spogliato e che sono diventano un
family friendly però che succede qua eh
ma non me le fa menare a si è quindi che
figo hai fregato caso ma dai che figata
li ho fregati quindi adesso poi menare i
bulli c'è qualcuno che allora qualcuno
per caso ho guardato il mio sempai ma
perché vivono tutti questo è nazista
anno sembrava sentite devo devo andare a
devo trovare qualcuno che non è seguito
da nessuno in modo da farlo fuori senza
farmi vedere tipo questa è la madonna a
posto qua non c'è niente da vedere
non c'è niente da vedere qua non c'è
niente vabbè mi sa che lo trovano il
corpo le tracce sono un pelo evidenti mi
sa che si capisce dove l'ho trascinato
però ok ok dovrei cambiarmi vestiti però
questa cosa non la posso far vedere anzi
potrei mettermi in jimi uniform ancora
meglio
dovrei trovare da qualche parte poi vedo
bene tutte le cose nuove che ci sono
perché ci sono un sacco di stanze nuove
tipo questa cosa sta roba qua leber
quanto è migliorato sul gioco da 1 a 1
milione è bellissimo
guarda ma se questo lo facessi fuori
qualche c'è già l'inceneritore non ne
faccio fuori 2
veloce aspetta aspetta tra calo tra
veloce veloce veloce veloce ti prego
velocissimo non c'è tempo buttato da
bravo bull veloce è perfetto attinente
benissimo giochino l'hanno fatto
funerale a quello lì potrebbe essere
scappato volo incenerito ma non è vero
gli hanno fatto veramente comunque un
cinico cona e la tua riva chieco con ha
anzi aspetta a proposito aspetta aspetta
aspetta
ecco a posto la deputazione più uno a
casa la tipa quei capelli viola e la mia
rivale perché era una tipa coi capelli
viola e chi era la mia rivale
fatemelo vedere ai codini sopra alle
pompe giganti cos'è l'angolo disagiati
questo classico murasaki non è questa
eccola
eccola e lei per forza più pop e di così
selphy kocon
eccola qua allora ma mi sembrava
poverina perché solo perché ai propri
giganti coltello quindi devo aspettare
che cocona se ne vada e la faccio fuori
va bene coco ana ma perché se in poi è
innamorato di questa strano proprio non
ne capisco il motivo devo aspettare che
vada in un punto dove non è visibile
così la faccio fuori sia poter poi fare
quello che stai facendo più veloce però
che cade nel latte alle ginocchia cona
ecco allora mi seguì un secondo per
favore con l'uniforme dico cona è troppo
stretta trova un modo per trovargliene
uno è un po più larga non è proprio
quello che vorrei fare
va bene è proprio difficile far fuori
una persona no andata arrivo al club del
drama ti prego che è rottura di tre
quarti sto club
mamma mia devo completare la mia task
per farmi seguire da lei e come faccio
come se la faccio fare adesso nessuno mi
vede così provare a farla foria e non
farvi vedere nessuno è difficilissimo
proviamoci laica misto cagato sotto tira
lap key dai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai
preghiamo ragazzi preghiamo che non esca
nessuno è forte se esce qualcuno dalla
porta questo è un problema
aspetta aspetta se qua chi se ne frega
delle chiazze st lascia lascia la non ho
fatto niente io ce sto facendo lo slalom
tra la gente
speriamo nomi si è fermata lì quella
cosa fai lì
muoviti ciò che si è mossa perfetto
perfetto tira tira tira km farlo
arrivare l'aiutava arrivare dal gioco e
l'albero li deve arrivare
devo arrivare laggiù che io sto
trascinando un corpo fuori dalla porta
spiega non ci sono il corridoio dai ce
la faccia ce la faccio
le scale le scale ragazzi no puoi andare
a farti cavoli tuoi per favore chi sei
chi ti conosce amiche verso sporco di
sangue e dovevo farla fuori raga ma l'ha
visto e lo sporco di sangue abbiamo
pensato
3222 fate fuori due vai dani porta a
tutt'e due nell'inceneritore
tutte e due via via via non è vero sto
gruppo di pezzenti nora che non ci credo
devo trovare un modo per evitarli questi
devo fare tutto un giro strano
faccio un giro largo magari non mi
vedono speriamo che un problema se no ok
da qua aspetto cioè di un po di tutto
sto schifo qua
che schifo devo pulire o no perché se mi
pulisco io come fanno a sapere che l'ho
trascinato io brucia solo l'arma e la
divisa va bene non ti beccano se non
pulisci va beh no no no no la modella
brucia l'arma l'arma sto bruciando no mi
beccano del suo show l'arma è la polizia
arriva a scuola elementare lo bruciato
l'arma trovati i corpi di coconut luca
sumero shakur è per forza porco demonio
morto quindi ragazzi che sono episodi di
gli under e ho fatto il live il live
succedono cose carine non era tanto
family friendly ma chi se ne frega
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto a me
un sacco per il momento mi piace anche
avere solo nei comuni tra schizzare se
non siamo così schietto come sempre ci
vediamo da ragazzi
[Musica]